this thing is not about
how successful it'll become this is
about me doing the best job i can and
that's what we try to do here
beloved comedian louis anderson has died
he was 68 years old i have to fight for
a lot of things
but it's still up to the public and
that's who i've always depended on
earlier this week the comic was
hospitalized while undergoing treatment
for blood cancer louie's rep confirmed
to e.t in a statement that the basket
star died of complications from the
disease
adding that he died peacefully friday
morning in las vegas what i'm really
just trying to do is build my reputation
i think i'm a
good actor and i think i'm a very good
comic and i would like to equal those
things out so that i was a very very
good actor in a very very good comics
louis a st paul minnesota native had a
career that spanned more than 40 years
the actor is perhaps best known for his
role as maurice in coming to america i
don't know how it is in africa but
here rich guys get all the chicks the
great thing about the movie is it's a
romantic comedy and i think people want
to see eddie in a romantic comedy i've
always had great respect and we've been
buddies you know he likes my stand up
and
i don't let my mom listen to his louis
even reprised his role in the 2021
sequel it's just good old-fashioned
grass
but he got his start in stand-up hitting
comedy stages all across the world and
in 1984 louie got his big break my next
guest is named uh louis anderson he's a
comedian he's making his first
appearance on national television i
can't stay long i'm in between meals so
bear with me
late night show icon johnny carson
invited the rising star to make his
national television debut on the tonight
show and let's just say the rest is
history of course what brought me to
california was the olympics i was
tried every event for the olympics try
that pole vault
i drove that sucker right into the
ground
in the 90s louie landed his own show
titled naturally the louis show i don't
know how i got roped into this people
are at their all-time sneakiest when
they're trying to get a ride to the
airport hey louie what are you doing
tomorrow oh nothing good could you give
me a ride to the airport oh sure
and although it was short-lived lasting
only one season louis shared with e.t
why the sitcom was important to him
first we're being funny because it isn't
about trying to deliver some huge
message it's trying to let people for a
half hour forget that the bills are due
that you know there's a crisis in the
family that you know the the water
heater needs to be fixed it's just a
half hour of having fun
absolutely having fun and that's my
first priority to this show then louie
added a new title to his resume game
show host
thank you thank you welcome to the
family feud from 1999 to 2002 the funny
man brought the laughs as the host on
family feud i never thought i'd do a
game show honestly but then um
i know it felt right
later in his career louis was given the
opportunity to stretch his range when he
landed the part of christine baskets on
the fx series baskets
is this a line to be heard on the senate
floor ah sure is oh
i wish i would have thought to bring a
chair in 2016 that role earned him his
first primetime emmy and a critics
choice award you know it's overwhelming
i'm humbled
i get a chance to bring my mom
in spirit
on the red carpet
louis is survived by his two sisters
lisa and shanna anderson
[Music]